هكذا يستيقظ سكان الخيام في هاتاي البرد
الذي ودعهم ليلا هو اول من يستقبلهم نهارا
شوادر ملال موزه عندي خمس اولاد
جربوا
لم يعد هناك سقف امن في عطاي انقلبت
الاسقف على رؤوس ساكنيها قتلت منهم الالاف
وشردت الناجين
بعضهم يعود اليها متحصرا والبعض الاخر
باحثا عما يبقيه متصلا بماضيه الجميل
زلزال قوي ماذا الشيء ابدا ما في ولايه
هذا البنايه الموجودين رايحين
لم يبقى لنا هنا اي شيء لا اعلم كيف سنعيش
لابني
راحة الدور الراعي اني ما اريد شيء
يصير اختي انا جيت من اسطنبول عليها
من علي تبدو انطاكيا مركز هاتاي متماسكه
ومتمسكه بعراقه تاريخها لكن ما ان تدقق
النظر حتى يتكشف حجم الدمار الذي لحق بها
خلال حدوث الزلزال خرجنا الى الشارع هنا
في الاعلى لم يحدث دمار كبير لكن هناك في
اسفل المدينه تدمرت بالكامل
مع افول الشمس ودفئها الذي يستانس به
الناجون خلال يومهم يحل البرد مجددا
ليسحبهم في ليلهم داخل هذه الخيام
ولانه لم يعد هناك سقف امن في هاتاي نقد
ليالينا تحت سقف هذه السياره ونحن بذلك
اوفر حظا من الاف يفترشون الارض في الخيام
عبد القادر خربوش العربيه